police searching for the person who
walked into a summerlin fast food
restaurant and opened fire a man was
killed and a cashier was injured inside
the store at town center and charleston
joe mohler they're live now with what we
know so far
joe brian this is normally a pretty busy
teriyaki madness location but take a
live look here this evening lights are
off doors shut and the note is on the
window there telling everybody it's
going to be closed for a few days after
that shooting left
one person dead and another injured many
people who come here still have a lot of
questions
i've been here eight years this is the
first
something like this has happened metro
says the shooting was a targeted
incident the shooter allegedly followed
a 40-year-old man inside and opened fire
a female employee who was a cashier was
also injured the shooter got away and is
still on the run now many people who
come here are concerned it's scary it's
happening a little bit more and more and
hopefully it stops because summerlin
really isn't known for that a note is
now in the door stating they will be
closed for a few more days
this note also expresses condolences to
that employee and the victim in this
shooting police don't have much
information to provide us they didn't
provide much of a description so if you
were out here and saw anything that may
help lead to an arrest they're asking
you to give them a call reporting live
in summerlin this evening john muller
live local now